Still   awake?
Something   on   your   mind?
Give   me   a   call,   three   two   three-K-L-five-KTRK.
Ask   to   speak   to   the   cute   one.
Hey,   all   you   night   owls.
Is   the   human   race   going   crazy   or
is   it   just   me?
Seems   like   all   you   hear   is   bad
news   lately.
Anybody   feel   the   same   way?
Feel   like   the   world's   cracking   at   the
seams?
Why   don't   we   make   that   the   topic
for   tonight?
And   if   that   doesn't   work,   you   can
all   go   back   to   calling   in   with
the   usual   pervert   stuff.
Line   five,   you're   on   with   the   Deb
of   Night.
So   tell   me,   society   going   to   hell
or   not?
I   think   so,   Deb.
And   why   is   that?
Well,   for   one,   I   lost   my   job
a   month   ago,   and   our   management   gave
themselves   a   bonus   for   it.
I'm   sorry   to   hear   it.
And   just   the   other   night,   I   happened
to   look   out   my   window   here   in
Santa   Monica,   which   used   to   be   a
nice   neighborhood.
I   saw   the   local   diner   where   I've
been   eating   my   breakfast   for   years   get
shot   to   pieces.
Can   you   believe   that?
Like,   no   one   cares   about   anyone   anymore.
I   hear   it.
And   my   neighbor's   boy,   sheesh,   he's   been
using   speed   since   he's   in   junior   high,
steals   from   his   parents.
That's   a   shame.
Yeah,   yeah.
You   know,   there   was   a   time   when
this   sort   of   thing   just   didn't   happen.
You   know   why?
Why   is   that?
Well,   because   a   man   could   beat   a
woman   and   children   when   they   got   out
of   line.
They   didn't   even   have   to   be   blood.
You   could   just   slap   the   little   bastards.
Ah,   the   good   old   days.
Why   don't   you   hit   the   activity   room
and   reminisce   some   more,   Grandpa?
Anyone   have   any   musings   that   don't   end
up   in   assault   charges?
Yeah,   hi.
Whoa,   here's   a   rare   event,   a   female
perspective   that   isn't   my   own.
Go   ahead,   sister.
Um,   [clears throat]   I   just   wanted   to   say
that   I   agree   with   you   for   the
most   part.
Things   have   really   started   to   suck   in
the   last   few   years.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
It's   like   I   can't   see   myself   bringing
a   child   into   this   world,   you   know?
I   hear   you.
Except   if   it   was,   like,   Ash   Rivers'
baby.
Oh,   he's   so   amazing,   Deb.
I   would,   like,   populate   a   minivan   for
him.
Oh   my   God.
Yeah,   but   what   are   the   chances   of
that   happening?
I   don't   know.
But   I'm,   like,   at   his   club   every
night.
[chuckles]   Okay.
But   back   to   the   topic.
Oh,   a-and   this   one   time,   I   was
working   as   a   waitress   at   this   awards
show,   and   I   served   him   a   drink,
and   he   told   me,   "Thanks,   beautiful."   And
there   was,   like,   a   moment,   definitely   something
there,   you   know?
Sure,   girl.
But   tonight's   topic   isn't   Ash   Rivers.
Yeah,   well,   that's   probably   really   good   because
all   of   you   other   females   better   stay
the   hell   away   from   him.
You   know   what   I   mean?
I'm   glad   to   provide   a   public   forum
for   the   whacked   out   of   both   sexes.
Let's   try   to   stay   on   topic,   shall
we?
Deb   of   Night?
That's   me.
I   recently   found   out   I   was   a
vampire.
[laughs]   Oh,   I   was   one   of   those
once,   and   then   it   was   November   first.
It's   not   a   joke.
I'm   really   worried   about   this.
Uh-huh.
This   girl   at   the   club   took   me
into   the   bathroom,   and   she   did   something
to   me.
Back   in   my   club   days,   we   used
to   call   that   a   favor.
Oh,   caller,   could   you   hold   on?
I've   got   Frankenstein   on   the   line.
Frankenstein,   something   you   want   to   add   to
this   conversation?
Rah!
I   see.
Your   rebuttal,   caller.
I'm   not   lying.
It   happened   to   me.
It   could   happen   to   anyone.
Fire.
Ah!
Ooh,   good   point.
You   want   some   advice?
Wash   off   the   eyeliner,   put   on   something
that's   not   black,   and   go   get   a
tan   at   the   beach.
Geez,   the   Deb   of   Night   Show   does
not   endorse   the   goth   lifestyle,   and   take
it   from   Deb,   pretending   you're   a   vampire
only   impresses   people   of   similar   physical   ickiness.
Next   caller.
Deb,   I   think   the   world's   been   messed
up,   is   messed   up,   and   will   continue
to   be   messed   up.
Oh,   an   optimist.
Now,   bear   with   me,   but   I   know
what   the   cause   of   all   the   world's
problems   is.
Nipples   on   TV?
Exactly.
Nudity?
Not   too   much   nudity.
Not   enough   nudity.
Clothes   make   a   person   dishonest.
They're   hiding   their   true   selves   away   under
them.
Clothes   promote   problems   like   class   and   sense
of   piety   and   concealed   weapons.
Why,   how   much   do   you   think   we
spend   on   clothes   as   a   people?
What   if   that   money   were   going   towards
science?
Why,   we'd   be   living   in   a   futuristic
techno   world   by   now.
Have   you   ever   been   to   a   nudist
colony?
Not   attractive.
The   fact   that   you   think   it   should
be   is   a   side   effect   of   the
prurient   media.
You're   not   desensitized   to   nudity.
Just   think,   if   the   man   at   the
movie   concession   wasn't   wearing   his   pants   today,
you'd   storm   out   of   the   theater   in
a   tizzy.
But   in   a   nude   world,   it'd   be,
"Popcorn   and   a   medium   soda,   please."   No,
I   think   what   would   happen   is   I'd
lose   my   appetite.
And   isn't   obesity   one   of   our   nation's
biggest   problems?
Another   benefit   of   nudity.
And   what   about   all   that   hullabaloo   that
people   make   when   a   person   walks   around
the   way   Mother   Nature   made   him   on
a   brisk   spring   afternoon,   arrested   for   public
indecency?
Why,   in   a   nude   world,   it'd   be
commonplace.
Folks   would   ask   you,   "How   many   people
did   you   expose   yourself   to   today?"   As
proud   as   I   am   of   my   girls,
I   think   I'm   gonna   limit   them   to
private   appearances.
Next   caller.
Deb,   this   is   it.
This   time   I've   stumbled   across   something   that's
bigger   than   anything   you   could   possibly   imagine,
a   threat   to   the   entire   human   race's
existence.
Ah,   Gomez.
You   know   it's   been   a   bad   night
when   I've   been   looking   forward   to   your
call.
Deb,   nothing   can   prepare   the   world   for
this.
This   is   the   biggest   story   in   the
history   of   humanity   ever.
Ever,   Deb.
How   I   found   this   out,   I   can't
say,   but   I'm   risking   my   life   to
tell   the   world   this.
Are   you   prepared   for   this?
Sure.
People   of   Los   Angeles,   vampires   walk   among
us.
Ugh,   not   vampires   again.
Hear   me   out,   Deb.
Vampires   are   among   us   and   have   been
since   the   dawn   of   time.
In   Los   Angeles,   well,   there's   more   vampires
per   person   here   than   anywhere   else   in
the   world.
People   are   killed   by   vampires   all   the
time,   but   their   secret   vampire   society   covers
it   up.
Who   blew   up   that   warehouse   in   Santa
Monica?
Vampires.
What   happened   to   the   crew   of   the
Elizabeth   Dane?
Vampires.
Want   to   know   what   happened   to   that
sarcophagus   that   disappeared?
Vampires   took   it.
The   Prince   of   Vampires,   to   be   more
specific.
He   wants   to   use   it   against   a
league   of   other   vampires   that   have   been
trying   to   get   a   foothold   in   our
city.
And   get   this,   there   could   be   an
even   older   vampire   in   the   sarcophagus,   an
ancient   super   vampire.
Right.
Vampires,   they're   everywhere.
You   can't   throw   a   rock   in   the
city   without   hitting   a   vampire.
Our   overlords   before
it's   too   late.
You   heard   him,   folks.
Gather   up   your   crosses,   garlic,   and   neck
braces.
Oh,   brother.
Well,   Deb's   not   undead,   but   the   sun'll
be   up   soon,   and   she's   dead   tired.
She's   going   home   to   get   some   hard-earned
R&R.
But   don't   worry,   she'll   be   back   same
time,   same   station   tomorrow   night.
Until   then,   fans,   don't   let   the   vampires
bite.
In   a   world   where   people   live   and
die...
Do   you   think   you   can   just   go
in   there   and   handle   this   by   yourself?
If   that's   what   it   takes.
He   was   about   to   meet   his   greatest
foe.
Kill   them   all!
All   of   them.
And   a   girl.
Hello.
Hi.
And   a   comic   relief   sidekick   who   won't
make   it   to   act   three.
I   picked   the   wrong   month   to   cancel
my   life   insurance.
No,   don't   say   that.
You're   gonna   make   it.
With   a   guy   from   that   other   movie
that   was   slightly   popular,   and   what's-her-name   from
that   show   you   sometimes   watch.
In   a   movie   with   two   spectacular   CGI
battle   sequences   and   an   advertising   campaign   that
will   leave   you   no   choice   but   to
see   this   film.
See   it   because   it's   a   movie   and
all   your   friends   are   going.
In   theaters   Friday   and   on   DVD   in
three   months.
Friggin'   Chicken   recently   challenged   several   random   people
to   a   taste   test   between   Friggin'   Chicken
and   the   other   leading   chicken   flavored   products.
Let's   listen   for   which   one   they   preferred.
Ma'am,   care   to   participate   in   a   taste
test?
Here,   try   this   leading   brand   of   chicken.
Ugh.
Oh,   my   gosh.
Is   that   week-old   fish?
Now,   try   this.
Oh.
Oh!
This   is   some   good   [beep]   chicken.
What   is   this?
Sir,   take   a   test   for   me?
Sure.
[munching]   Seriously,   shove   these   up   your   [beep]
.
Here,   try   this   one.
Mm.
Hey.
Mother [beep]   great   chicken   right   there.
What   is   this?
It's   Friggin'   Chicken.
This   is   cat,   right?
Are   you   feeding   me   cat?
Try   this.
Holy   [beep].
[beep]   that's   good.
What   the   [beep]   is   this   [beep]?
Nine   out   of   10   people   preferred   Friggin'
Chicken   over   the   competition.
Why?
'Cause   that's   some   good   [beep]   chicken.
I   mean,   Friggin'   Chicken.
Friggin'   Chicken,   you'll   swear   it's   the   best
you've   ever   had.
[horn honking]   Phil's   here.
Gotta   run.
Great   breakfast,   honey.
Have   a   good   day,   dear.
I'm   glad   you   liked   the   muffins.
Hey,   what's   that   on   the   counter?
That's   not   my   margarine,   that's   butter.
It's-   [punching]   [beep]   You   know   I'm   supposed
to   watch   my   LDL   levels.
[crying]   I,   I   thought   it   would   be
a   nice   change.
You   couldn't   even   tell.
You   don't   want   a   divorce,   you're   trying
to   kill   me.
I'm   glad   I   slept   with   your   sister.
[door slamming]   I   thought   it   was   margarine,   grade
B   butter.
Other   ants   who   tasted   margarine   with   all
the   saturated   fat   of   butter.
[horn honking]   Phil's   here.
Gotta   run.
Great   breakfast,   honey.
Have   a   good   day,   dear.
I'm   glad   you   liked   the   muffins.
Hey,   what's   that   on   the   counter?
That's   not   my   margarine,   that's   butter.
It's-   [punching]   [beep]   You   know   I'm   supposed
to   watch   my   LDL   levels.
[crying]   I,   I   thought   it   would   be
a   nice   change.
You   couldn't   even   tell.
You   don't   want   a   divorce,   you're   trying
to   kill   me.
I'm   glad   I   slept   with   your   sister.
[door slamming]   I   thought   it   was   margarine,   grade
B   butter.
Other   ants   who   tasted   margarine   with   all
the   saturated   fat   of   butter.
You   love   the   talking   baby   movie   and
the   talking   pig,   and   even   the   talking
car   in   that   show.
You   know   the   one   I'm   talking   about.
But   now   prepare   for   the   most   hilarious
talking-est   normally   mute   object   yet.
He's   Steve   Cash,   a   New   York   banker
and   recent   widower   down   on   his   luck.
And   10   makes   100.
Here's   your   money,   ma'am.
Ma'am,   I   happen   to   have   a   glandular
problem.
That's   it,   I'm   withdrawing   all   my   millions
from   this   bank.
Cash!
[laughing]   She's   an   ATM   machine   with   the
soul   of   his   dead   wife.
There's   something   familiar   about   this   ATM   machine.
I   love   you.
Wow,   those   marketing   guys   are   geniuses.
[laughing]   Together,   they're   learning   to   make   the
most   of   their   special   situation.
So   that   girl   from   accounting   used   me
today.
Really?
She   wasn't   like   everybody   else.
When   she   pushed   my   buttons,   she   was
very   gentle.
Oh,   honey,   if   you   don't   stop   I'm
gonna   have   to   make   a   deposit.
[laughing]
Transferring   Cash,   Wednesdays   at   8:30   in   the
BMC.
Does   your   penis   always   seem   to   be
getting   in   the   way?
I   got   the   last   of   the   groceries,
honey.
I   just   need   to   close   the   trunk.
[trunk closing]   [screaming]   One   more   nail   and   this
birdhouse   will   be   as   good   as   new.
[hammer hitting wood]   [screaming]   I'm   sorry,   sir,   this   dressing
room   is   for   women   only.
You   don't   have   to   let   this   happen
to   you.
Hi,   I'm   Dr.
Fred   Tuck.
Don't   let   your   penis   interfere   with   the
quality   of   your   life   anymore.
I   have   performed   over   300   sex   changes
in   my   career,   and   not   one   of
my   patients   has   ever   asked   for   their
tackle   box   back.
Come   to   Tuck's   Sex   Exchange   in   the
next   month   and   I'll   give   you   a
free   estimate.
Don't   let   your   piece   interfere   with   your
peace   of   mind.
Tuck's   Sex   Exchange,   located   off   Beverly   Drive.
Look   for   the   sign   with   Toothy,   the
surgical   saw.
You   live.
[birds chirping]   You   die.
[bell tolling]   And   sometimes   you   get   brought   back
to   life.
[lightning striking]   [growling]   This   fall.
I'm   afraid   I   can't   see   too   well
these   days.
Do   you   think   you   could   go   to
the   nearest   village   and   pick   me   up
a   loaf   of   bread?
Bread.
Good.
The   new   horror   RPG   from   Troika   Games.
Bread!
Oh,   I   can   tell   you   where   the
bakery   is,   stranger.
But   before   I   do,   would   you   mind
picking   up   my   little   girl   from   the
lake?
You   are   the   monster.
[woman screaming]   Or   are   you?
If   you   wanna   enter   this   bakery,   you'll
have   to   defeat   me.
And   this   torch.
[fire whooshing]   Frankenstein:   Breadlust,   coming   soon   to   a
PC   near   you.
Game.
Good.
Ah,   would   you   look   at   this.
What's   that?
Plague   of   locusts   descend   on   small   Indian
town.
Jeez,   I   can't   imagine   what   that   must
be   like.
And   look   at   this,   civil   war   still
raging   between   ethnic   factions   in   Eastern   Europe.
Yeah,   heard   about   that   And   in   Zimbabwe,
they   got   to   use   oxcarts   for   ambulances.
That's   terrible.
Hey,   it's   a   good   thing   we   live
in   the   US.
It   sure   is,   buddy.
Hey,   bartender,   two   more   US   ales.
US   Ale.
Welcome   to   the   United   States   of   Inebriation.
[rock music]
In   the   violet   silence   of   a   dream
within   a   dream.
You   fill   my   soul   with   beauty,   you're
my   shining   machine.
Sinking   in   the   roses   falling   down   to
free   you,   baby.
Your   velvet   play   of   apathy   makes   the
crush   so   bittersweet.
And   I,   I   could   have   died   last
night.
But   I   heard   the   voice   of   a
smiling   god.
And   I,   I   could   have   died   last
night.
But   I   heard   the   voice   of   a
smiling   god.
[rock music]
Your   presence   is   the   morning,   your   absence
is   the   night.
I'm   searching   your   dark   hallways,   and   I'm
trying   to   find   your   light.
Swimming   your   sad   oceans,   I'm   drowning   in
your   sea.
This   will   all   be   over   soon,   and
we'll   learn   to   live   again.
And   I,   I   could   have   died   last
night.
But   I   heard   the   voice   of   a
smiling   god.
And   I,   I   could   have   died   last
night.
But   I   heard   the   voice   of   a
smiling   god.
Between   stars   I   see   your   eyes,
I   hear   you   speak   to   me.
I   miss   you   now   so   much   it
aches.
So   broken,   so   afraid.
[rock music]
And   I,   I   could   have   died   last
night.
But   I   heard   the   voice   of   a
smiling   god.
And   I,   I   could   have   died   last
night.
But   I   heard   the   voice   of   a
smiling   god.
[rock music]   Oh,   oh-oh.
Oh,
oh-oh.
Oh,   oh-oh-oh-oh.
[rock music]
I   bite,   you   bleed.
You   pray,   I   feed.
You   cry,   I   won't.
You   die,
I   don't.
I   recall
when   we   were   first   introduced.
You   were
tired   and   broken   and   confused.
The   walls   you   built   kept   crumbling   in.
Your   life   of   lies   hiding   you   within.
Just   one   taste   of   nectar   from   this
spoon.
Now   you   can't   walk   away,   tomorrow   comes
too   soon.
I   bite,   you   bleed.
You   pray,   I   feed.
You   cry,   I   won't.
You   die,
I   don't
I   will   make   you   feel   this   way
forever.
I   am   the   only   one   of   us
to   stay   together.
I   will   never   turn   away,   I   am
not   afraid.
I   know   you   could   never   wipe   my
kiss   away.
Clench   your   hand   into   fists.
Hold   me   as   we   kiss.
I   know   you   can't   pull   away.
Our   hot   love   fills   your   veins.
I   bite,   you   bleed.
You   pray,   I   feed.
You   cry,   I   won't.
You   die,
I   don't.
So   you've   lost   count   of   days
since   I   came   to   take   your   pain
away.
Now   you   don't   have   the   strength   to
survive.
Your   last   sign   of   liberation
is   to   the   needle's   eye.
I
bite,   you   bleed.
You   pray,   I   feed.
You   cry,   I   won't.
You   die.
I   bite,   you   bleed.
You   pray,   I   feed.
You   cry,   I   won't.
You   die,
I   don't